tiffani g7 why do men have nipples
Tiffany come on you're gonna ask me the
hard questions hey guys what is up my
god the channel is growing so fast and
I'm here with another episode of
responding to your comments I'm really
loving the interaction and growth that's
happening on the channel I mean you guys
are killing it the medical reaction
series is like well Grey's Anatomy just
hit 10 million views subscribe subscribe
subscribe cuz that tells YouTube that
you're really enjoying the channel so
let's get started
time to respond and read some comments
why do men have nipples this is not
something they taught us in medical
school and I hate when people say that
they're like Mike you don't know that
they didn't teach you that in medical
school no I didn't have men's nipples
101 is one of my classes that I was
taking I was taking pathophysiology in
microbiology and pharmacology learning
about how drugs enter your system and
how they leave your system much more
complex stuff than that but I guess I
should probably look into why men have
nipples interesting question Tiffany
I'll get back to you this has always
killed me and I want to know your
opinion on this doctors and nurses see
the effects cancer has on the body so
why do so many of them smoke me hi what
a great great question
you know it's funny me hi my father
who's a doctor I've mentioned it before
actually smoked for about ten years when
he was younger
up until all the time he became a doctor
and started to see the consequences of
smoking and immediately stopped but
there are a lot of doctors who because
of their very stressful lives because of
the burnout that they experience in
their hectic day-to-day job actually
start smoking or maybe even continue
smoking it's a horrible habit and just
because you know that it shortens your
life just because you know it can bring
disease doesn't always convince people
to not smoke I will say this smoking
rates at an all-time low the percentage
of smokers has dropped into the teens
and that's such a huge accomplishment
for the United States in pain is that
really your username in pain I hope
you're not in pain how long did it take
you to get used to the sight of blood or
were you fine with it from the start
have any of the procedures you've done
make you nauseous or even come back to
haunt you and your dreams oh my god this
is so
great question blood never made me
nauseous
I always just viewed it as part of the
job and it didn't faze me in any way
really I will tell you I have a thing
with gagging you know when you go see
the dentist and they put the dental mold
on you I mean I've had braces twice so
I've had those molds put in a ton I get
the biggest anxiety when they put the
molds in because I could feel the mold
scratch the back of my throat and it
triggers my gag reflex it gives me the
most anxiety and I have to literally sit
there and put all my willpower to make
sure that I don't freak out having the
mold in my mouth and I guess from that
there's a procedure we do in the
hospital called the nasal gastric tube
insertion it's basically you put in a
tube that goes into through the nose and
it goes into the stomach we can use that
to feed patients that aren't able to
swallow we can use it to pull content
out of the stomach for suctioning
purposes sometimes patients gag
something to do with gagging makes me
gag also so please know I'm getting
nauseous thinking about it we have to
stop this question right now everything
wrong with my channel what my doctor's
an old Chinese man who tells me I need
to get married soon still grateful
though should you get married I don't
know what's your life like are you happy
with your partner or do you have a
partner do you want to get married who's
this old Chinese man Annika
what's your opinion on vaping I'm
probably gonna get torn apart for this
because I am NOT a fan of vaping even
though a lot of these companies like Jul
are coming out and saying that their
products are an alternative to smoking
what the evidence has shown so far is
that people who don't smoke start vaping
especially kids and yes they put some
money towards making sure that kids
don't start by advertising the dangers
of vaping and making sure it's not
advertised to kids but in reality kids
are gonna start doing it because they
make flavors like cotton candy and
bubble gum like of course kids are gonna
do it so no I am NOT a fan of vaping I
will go on record and say it's probably
not as hazardous as
additional smoking cigarettes but it
still has chemicals you're still
inhaling chemicals some of the flavors
have propylene glycol in them which has
been known to cause a condition called
popcorn lung I mean you don't want any
of these conditions and in reality the
thing that makes all of these substances
dangerous whether you're talking about
cigarettes or vaping is nicotine
nicotine is an addictive substance it
constricts your blood vessels which can
cause an array of problems from having a
stroke from having heart attacks this is
not something you want for your body if
you're gonna use a vape pen to gradually
get off cigarettes okay then that's fine
but there's no other use for them you
shouldn't just use them for your
pleasure that's just my take ray Ocasio
can you confirm or deny the conception
that pimping ain't easy it ain't easy
but it ain't bright either if you're
pimping in the literal sense you should
be in jail and if you're pimping cuz you
got swag and all that that's still ain't
easy so props to you ELISA who Mun Yoon
do you have good handwriting or not
please like so he sees this message well
you don't have to like it because I saw
the message and I'm gonna answer you
honestly I got good grades but in
cursive I got my lowest grades I mean my
mom had to sit there with me teaching me
how to write in scrip cuz I was so bad I
couldn't stay within the lines and the
spaces and half of the letters would be
capitals half of them will be lowercase
I have the traditional doctor's
handwriting this was even a joke I
remember in my Taekwondo school when I
filled out the applications for
tournaments people would say oh my God
look his dad's a doctor he has doctors
handwriting so no my handwriting is bad
but I will say I've worked really hard
to make it legible so you can read it
but it looks like a third grader who
wrote it Sam tablet - can doctors
diagnose themselves and prescribe
themselves medication Sam it's not
illegal for doctors to prescribe
themselves medication but it's ethically
questionable so doctors generally
shouldn't do it but I mean if you need
to write yourself an allergy medication
or
in antibiotic it's really not a big deal
but I will say this you're not being the
best doctor the most objective doctor
when you're treating yourself because
you often think you know what's right or
what's better for you than what another
doctor may that kind of bias to affect
your medical judgment clarity by a kun
Saluki and joon-kook hey dr. Mike do you
hear Yanni or Laurel I hear yanny
or Laurel yeah oh I heard Laurel it's
something to do his frequency of hearing
and I heard it something to do with how
old you are but I'm only 28 and I hear
Laurel which is supposed to be for older
folks scientists explain it to me DMS -
do you use a squatty potty using one as
I type gross TMI but no I don't use a
squatty potty I don't think you have to
raise up your legs in order to poop
effectively I think that's a marketer
trying to sell you a piece of plastic to
put onto Neath your toilet because
they're an IKE a marketer expert if you
don't know what a Nike market or expert
is click and watch my TED talk
Regina phalanges Rutina phalanges that's
from friends I'm Regina phalange so how
should we clean our ears what is the
right way Regina the right way is to
only clean the outside of your ears you
can use q-tips but they have to be on
the outside inserting anything into your
ears is a huge nono the problem is with
the q-tip is they push the earwax
further in they irritate the canal and
those are things you don't want to do if
you feel like you have a lot of earwax
you have two options one go to a
pharmacy and pick up some
over-the-counter earwax dissolving
solution you can put some drops in it'll
take a few days and it'll dissolve the
earwax and will come out naturally on
its own or to go see your family
medicine doctor and we have a lot of
tools that we can use to clean out your
ears and get the earwax out safely
without irritating your canals or
hurting your tympanic membrane which is
the part of the middle ear that helps
you hear Emily Z every time I watch you
I feel like I've grown a brain cell well
Emily you don't really grow brain cells
but what you're doing is you're
strengthening the contacts between your
neurons which allows you to piece the
information that I'm putting
your brain right now and allow it to be
access later so you can make better
decisions about your health Reese girl
50 plays what are your thoughts on
makeup but do you think it's okay for
young teens to wear pounds of it every
day there's probably nothing wrong with
it I'm not a huge fan of makeup I get
that you have to wear makeup for
television when I do TV they do put
makeup on making sure that you take it
off every night is smart so you don't
clog your pores and become prone to
breakouts
but otherwise I think it's fun as long
as you're not doing it for any negative
reasons that like you have body
dysmorphic disorder and you hate the way
you look or something along those lines
then I think it's just a creative outlet
that you can use to express yourself
love Charlie
what causes hiccups is there a way to
stop them once they start hiccups is
just a little spasm going on in your
diaphragm which is the muscle
immediately below your lungs the way
that works for me to cure hiccups is to
eat a spoonful of sugar it's so weird
but it works for me I don't know what
the medical reasoning for it is but it
works other things that I've heard in
the past is if you chug a full glass of
water tilting your head back
someone's scaring you but really the
spoonful of sugar has always worked for
me it's like a hundred percent effective
for me to work for my friends I mean as
long as you're not diabetic and you're
not doing anything crazy maybe try it
for yourself
kcb mike is so cute wow I can't believe
he's real he's probably a hologram I
promise I am NOT a hologram
Alonzo barrientos do a draw my life
Alonzo I want to do a draw my life if
anyone knows a great animator who can
help me out with that please tag them
below in the comments send them an email
because I really can't save my life you
don't want to draw my life from me doing
a Maury you should do medical ASMR you
know I've seen some of these ASMR things
they're like people like
doing noises like this right is this a
medical ASM Marco's Vinicius Garcia
Lazaro hey doctor Mike big fan I have to
use the microwave every day to heat my
lunch at work is there any risk by doing
that no there's no risk don't worry
about microwaves period end of story
don't go any of these crazy websites
where people like microwaves are gonna
cause cancer and kill you yes don't
stand in front of the microwave for long
periods of time use it don't be afraid
of it if there comes out some breaking
story where we find out that microwaves
are bad for you because of proven
research I will be one of the first
people to tell you that and you will see
it all across the news you know as I say
be alert not anxious hey Doc I recently
went through something where a few
surgeons changed my life for the better
and honestly I'm so thankful I feel like
I owe them my life what are some good
ways to thank medical professionals
gifts thank-you letters just a verbal
thanks or anything else love your videos
very happy to hear that you had a
positive medical outcome from your
surgeons do something like this it's
called a letter of gratitude write a
letter to whichever doctor that you
think helped you along your journey
thanking them expressing your gratitude
being as open and honest as possible and
don't send it to them either make an
appointment to see them or just drive by
and for a social visit and read the
letter out loud to them not only is that
going to be incredibly powerful for them
but it's gonna be powerful for yourself
in fact we've seen the letter of
gratitude as a psychological experiment
decrease symptoms of anxiety and
depression in people for 3-4 weeks six
weeks after reading the letter write a
letter of gratitude and let me know down
below how that whole process works out
you've done an amazing job asking me
some really tough questions and you're
helping me stay sharp as a doctor as
much as I'm helping you gain more
medical wisdom so keep your questions
coming keep the humor coming I'm really
enjoying it as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]